يا للطقس بالخارج
مخيف وسنزداد سوءًا خلال
الأيام القليلة المقبلة ، لذا من الضروري أن
تكون مستعدًا لمحاربة البرد
مع تحذير خدمة الأرصاد الجوية الوطنية من
برودة الرياح التي تهدد الحياة في بعض
أجزاء البلاد.
شيء واحد يمكنك القيام به للبقاء آمنًا هو البقاء في
الداخل ، فنحن نقول حقًا للناس بالحد
من تعرضهم خارج Kelly cyr ، يقول
خبير الأرصاد الجوية بالتنسيق التحذيري مع
خدمة الطقس إن قضمة الصقيع يمكن أن
تحدث بشكل أسرع مما تعتقد في
درجات الحرارة السلبية جنبًا إلى جنب مع
الرياح القوية التي تخلق بالفعل  هذه
الظروف الخطرة على البشر ، فالأمر
يستغرق بضع دقائق فقط من
خمس إلى عشر دقائق
ويمكن أن يبدأ جلدك في التجمد أيضًا ولا
تسلك الطرق إلا إذا كان عليك
التأكد من أن لديك مجموعة طوارئ في
سيارتك وأن  ستحافظ مجموعة أدوات الطوارئ
على أنك ستحافظ على الأشياء
التي ستبقيك دافئًا في
حالة تقطعت بك السبل أو توقف سيارتك عن
ذلك  تريد التأكد من حصولك
على القبعة والقفازات
وبطانيات معطف الشتاء الدافئ وبعض الطعام الإضافي
تأكد من أن هاتفك المحمول معك
شاحن بطارية خارجي
إضافي لهاتفك الخلوي حتى تتمكن من الاتصال
للحصول على المساعدة واتخاذ الإجراءات المناسبة  الاحتياطات في
الداخل أيضًا ارتد ملابس دافئة احتفظ بحيواناتك الأليفة
بالداخل ضع صنابير المياه بالتنقيط قليلاً
لمنع الأنابيب المتجمدة في حالة انقطاع التيار الكهربائي ،
لا تترك الشموع دون رقابة
ولا تستخدم أبدًا شوايات المولدات أو
مواقد المخيم في الداخل أو بالقرب من النوافذ
في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم.  إيفان رودريغيز